in this video we will explain all 11
mythical zones in one piece we'll start
with marco the phoenix and in the later
parts of the video we'll explain some
far more interesting mythical zones
marco the phoenix is the former first
division commander of the whitebeard
pirates once starting out as an
apprentice in the crew he had come to be
whitebeard's closest confidant and
right-hand man after his captain's death
marco assumed leadership of the
whitebeard pirates until the crew's
disbandment following the payback war
tori tori no me is the devil fruit that
allows marco to transfer him into a
phoenix and a human phoenix hybrid it
will he has a very well developed
mastery over his transformation allowing
him to alter select parts of his body as
he needs to this power is the source of
his nickname marco the phoenix as a zoan
marco enjoys a great boost to his
physical abilities becoming strong
enough to restrain two extremely
powerful ancient zoan users at once
furthermore as a bird type zone margot
gains wings that allow him to fly in
both his hybrid form and full phoenix
form as well as talon bird legs that he
can use to perform powerful kicks or
slash enemies with marco can freely
create his blue flames of resurrection
from any part of his body even without
actually transforming and they always
cover him while transformed these
phoenix flames are stronger than normal
fire and possess tremendous healing
properties while shrouded in the flames
marco can rapidly self-regenerate from
almost any physical damage he receives
like a phoenix being reborn such immense
recovery power allows marco to ward off
extremely potent attacks with little
issue like kizaru's volley of light
bullets or even a kainu's magma punch
marco can also share his healing flame
with others allowing him to mend them as
well even multiple individuals at once
however his flames are less effective on
anyone other than himself the next
mythical zone on our list is lyken
alright i'm just kidding he's actually
the character from bloodline heroes of
lithas which is the sponsor of today's
video bloodline heroes of lithus is a
free-to-play card based fantasy rpg
where you can collect champions build
kingdoms and also create legendary heirs
of your house by combining various
bloodlines such as orcs werewolves
demons and dragonborn customize your
champions by marrying different
bloodlines until you find a unique
combination of abilities that suits your
own gameplay i was really surprised by
how many interesting characters there
are if you're new to the game i
definitely recommend you try lykins
they're a lineage of werewolves with
super cool designs level up yourself to
unlock more companions for free the
higher your companion intimacy the more
powerful your offspring will be if you
want to create even more powerful
offspring keep developing your family
tree until your champion inherits all
the best traits you want for a limited
amount of time you can also get this
insanely powerful half dragonborn half
demigod air for free what are you
waiting for download the game now using
my link in the description or by
scanning the qr code here on the screen
you can also use my gift code to obtain
rewards worth 20
this includes 20 intimacy packs 100 000
gold and 100 diamond thank you bloodline
for sponsoring this video and i'll see
you guys in game number two sengoku
alongside garp in suru sengoku is one of
the most powerful marines of his
generation even without his own devil
fruit powers sengoku has enormous
strength enough to effortlessly hold
down an enraged garp with only one hand
sengoku is also a tremendously skilled
hand-to-hand fighter when shiki was
wreaking havoc in marine ford 22 years
ago sengoku fought alongside garp and
was able to subdue him whilst destroying
half the city in the process keeping him
imprisoned in impel down this is a
tremendous feat as shiki is an immensely
powerful swordsman who had
single-handedly slaughtered an entire
army of marines before they subjugated
him sengoku ate the hirohito nomi model
daibutsu a mythical zoan type devil
fruit that allows him to transform into
a giant golden buddha and a human buddha
hybrid a number of marines claim that
they have never seen him use this power
before the war sengoku gains an immense
boost to his already impressive physical
abilities while in his buddha form with
only a single indirectly connecting
punch sengoku was able to make the
marine ford execution platform collapse
despite the punch being cushioned and
blocked by luffy's gear 3 inflated belly
and mr 3's stronger than steel candle
wall he can also release an
exceptionally powerful golden shock wave
with a palm thrust it's strong enough to
send a majority of the incredibly strong
blackbeard pirates consisting of some of
the most dangerous criminals in history
flying a fair distance away his golden
shock waves are strong enough to clash
evenly with the tremor shock waves
created by the guru guru nomi nine more
mythical zoans are left and trust me you
don't want to miss a single one number
three patrick redfield according to
sengoku red was powerful enough to
single-handedly rival the pirate king
gold roger and emperor edward newgate
during his prime even in old age where
he claimed to have significantly
weakened from senescence he fought the
straw hat pirates an extremely
formidable crew multiple times with
little injury he has impeccable speed
and leg strength dodging the crew's
attacks and knocking luffy unconscious
with one kick despite his age he was
also exceptionally durable withstanding
a combined attack from the straw hat
crew while only being slightly injured
from the assault after eating the
mythical zoan type devil fruit during
the final confrontation of the game he
gains the ability to transform into a
full vampire this gives the user the
ability to fly create a cloud to cloak
themselves and an apparent form of
teleportation by appearing in
disappearing in blood red bursts of
energy the strongest power that this
fruit grants to red is the ability to
suck someone else's life force either by
biting the victim's neck or digging his
nails into the victim's skin by sucking
the victim's life force he can age them
to regain his own youth with red
implying the fruit grants immortality in
eternal youth as long as there is life
force for the user to drain the user can
also return the life force to their
victims if they choose to do so and
there was no ill effects to the victims
after their life force was returned it's
unknown if the fruit gives the user the
usual weaknesses of a vampire such as
sunlight garlic or crosses but the user
does require taking another person's
life force to use the fruit's powers to
its full potential number four kaido
kaido of the beast renowned as the
world's strongest creature is the
governor general of the beast pirates
and one of the four emperors ruling over
the new world as one of the four
emperors kaido is one of the strongest
pirates alive notably he has a bounty of
four billion six hundred million belly
which is the highest known bounty of any
pirate currently alive and the third
highest in history surpassed only by the
bounties of the late whitebeard and
goldie roger kaido ate the
model
a mythical zoan type devil fruit this
fruit enables the user to turn into a
giant serpentine blue-scaled dragon and
into a human dragon hybrid apart from
scales acquired dragon features include
horns a second pair in kaido's case
sharp fangs and limbs with clawed hands
and feet in his full beast form kyle
grows to rival a small town in size
making this the largest scene zoen
transformation his human beast form
while not as colossal is still very
large and in shape comes closer to his
human form as with all zoans the user's
transformation significantly boosts
their physical abilities the full
dragon's form strength befits its size
as the user can severely damage
structures like houses merely by
brushing by them when kaido flew around
okubore town in a drunken stupor it was
believed that if he continued wreaking
havoc senselessly not just the town but
kuri itself would get wiped out in the
anime the full dragon form's powers
further exemplified with kaido seen
causing intense gusty shock waves simply
by moving through the air he was able to
send luffy flying with immense force
using a tail swipe and easily
overpowered luffy's hockey and use of
gear 3 with one of his dragon hands two
decades ago in his fight with kozuki
odin kaido and his beast form repeatedly
clashed with the samurai on even terms
including matching the force of odin's
togen shirataki with his head countering
his blades with his claws and fangs and
even using one of his mustache tendrils
to ensnare and toss out in a way apart
from raw strength kaido is also very
fast in this form as he can move about
at great speeds while keeping pace with
significantly fast human sized foes the
scales covering his dragon body are
noted to be extremely durable blows of
incredible power including ones
strengthened by regular busochoku haki
have proven utterly ineffective at
hurting kaido nonetheless as with
kaido's extremely tough human skin his
dragon scales can be penetrated and
blood drawn from him using attacks that
bypass external defenses like advanced
grade buso shoku haki number 5. katarina
devin katarina devin is stated to be the
most dangerous female pirate in history
though not to the same degree as big mom
another testament to her power is the
fact that when blackbeard recruited the
level 6 prisoners he only chose the
strongest ones that could survive when
pitted against everyone else in a
free-for-all battle thus katarina devon
is one of the strongest level 6
prisoners having been promoted to the
captain of the sixth ship serves as a
testament to teach his trust in her
powers along with granting her the
authority over the lower ranking members
she's strong enough to injure even
whitebeard using her spear although
whitebeard was already greatly weakened
at that point she's also been shown to
have great superhuman endurance taking
both a guru guru nomi shock wave from
whitebeard and sengoku's shockwave in
his buddha form and getting up rather
easily definite the inuino no meme model
cubie no kitsune a mythical zoan type
devil fruit that allows her to transform
into a nine-tailed fox as such they gain
all the abilities of one including the
ability to disguise themselves as anyone
they like allowing them to impersonate
them the clothing of the target person
can also be imitated during the
transformation number six monkey d luffy
when he was seven years old luffy
unwittingly ate the gomegomanumi a
paramecia type devil fruit after finding
it in a chest owned by the red hair
pirates it gives his body the properties
of rubber allowing him to stretch bounce
bend twist and inflate any part of his
body initially luffy was unable to
control his stretching but was able to
master it after 10 years of training on
dawn island and further master it during
the two years he spent training with
silver's relay on rusukina during the
wano arc it was revealed that it's
actually a mythical zoan type double
fruit the hirohito no me model nica
which allows the user to become an
incarnation of nika the sun god this
grants luffy's body rubber physiology
and allows him to fight however he
pleases just as long as he can imagine
it according to the five elders because
of the smiles nika can put on the faces
of others he's known as the warrior of
liberation it has been said that there
is no power more ridiculous in all the
world aligning with the mythical zoan
nature of this new form luffy's already
rubbery body gains strength freedom and
durability that surpasses what he would
receive from his previous forms to the
point that it's now even cartoonishly
malleable with kaido likening it to
something out of a picture book an
example of this is when he reactivated
gear 5 and took a hit to the head from
kaido's huslakai only for his head to
warp and wrap around the weapon in its
spikes or when kaido tried to smash him
into the ground his body was simply
squished instead and later returned to
its original shape luffy's rubbery
nature can be extended into the
environment around him as see when luffy
stretched a section of the roof and used
it to bounce kaido's bolo breath back at
him interestingly the altered terrain
was neither burnt nor melted by the bowl
of breath movie can affect his
surroundings to the point where he can
make surfaces like the ground beneath
him rubbery to cushion himself from
powerful blows and even bounce off and
latch himself off of whatever surface
his power affects despite the strength
of this form due to inexperience it
consumes plenty of energy to maintain
and use at which point luffy will
visibly age once knee transformed that
said luffy can transform him back by
seemingly forcing his heart to beat in
the rhythm of the drums of liberation in
addition luffy still has his standard
weakness to cutting attacks number 7
toratsugu toritsugu ate the toritorino
a mythical zooan type devil fruit that
allows him to transform into the
legendary yokai nui as of the nue
torusugu is capable of flight and is
large enough to carry people on his back
in this form he's somewhat skilled in
combat being able to overwhelm prince
lerk but having been overpowered by
luffy quickly doratsugu claimed to be a
master florist and a capable teacher in
ikebana number eight orochi orochi is
the former shogun of wano county and one
of the last members of the kurozumi
family he ate the heavy heavy no meme
model yamata no orochi a mythical zoan
type devil fruit this fruit granted him
eight separate heads each one with an
extremely long neck and each one capable
of speech on their own it appears that
the user has some degree of control over
the number of heads that can spread at
once with eight being the maximum limit
curiously some of orochi's human form
features such as his crown and mustache
are present only in one of the heads
while the other seven possess a simpler
and more generic appearance as a zoen
orochi received a boost to his physical
abilities though he was never seen using
his enhanced physical capabilities in
battle however in his eight-headed
serpent dragon form he was able to deal
considerable damage to the room he was
in and attacked the people who were
there with him he was also strong enough
to easily lift up a person with just one
of his bounds furthermore he is able to
attack and trap their targets with his
considerably strong jaws orochi also has
an incredible amount of durability in
his transformed state being capable of
sustaining damage from a ceiling
collapsing on his head with few
repercussions the fruit's multiple heads
also allow the user to survive
decapitation even in human form only
three mythical zoans are left and the
next one is oni mario onimaru is a
komagitsune who was once the companion
of the late daimyo of ringo shimotsuki
ushimaru after the death of his master
he joined forces with kawamatsu and
collecting weapons for the final battle
against kaido and protecting them from
robbers after kawamatsu was captured
onimaru posed as a human stealing
weapons from people while continuing to
guard the graves onimaru ate the
hirohito nomi model onido a mythical
zoan type devil fruit that allows him to
transform into a full monk yokai and a
fox monk hybrid onimaru is able to
transform into a large human aid who is
known as yukimaru as gukimaru he is
capable of human speech his jaw is quite
strong as he was able to instantly cause
considerable injury to kawamatsu's arm
by biting it he also has considerable
endurance as he stood to protect the
graves after being struck by arrows and
in the present day he was able to
withstand a bazooka shot from one of the
beast's pirates befitting his size
gykimoto has enormous strength as he
could match zoto's physical power he
also had great speed able to match
zoro's agility though in their next
match he was overwhelmed by zorro
implying he might have had an advantage
in the first match because he caught the
swordsman off guard number 10. pato due
to his mythical zoen type double fruit
ability pato can transform into a baked
banuki from his original pen form
although he's usually in his zoen form
the most basic strength of the fruit is
that it gives its user strengths and
powers of a monster raccoon dog in the
case of pato the fruit's major strength
is that it has given life to an
otherwise inanimate object an object
that has been given life by this fruit
will also have sapien intelligence and
the ability to speak this power gives
the user specific traits of the mythical
raccoon dog in which it can transform
ordinary leaves into anything else from
objects to other people and entire
environments in pato's case he must
write a name on the leaf with his pen
tail for it to transform the individuals
the user creates have the same exact
abilities as the originals and are
utterly loyal to the user they can even
create copies of themselves the people
that the user creates aren't as powerful
as the originals and will turn back into
leaves once defeated this was shown when
the real straw hat pirates easily
defeated an army of clones which
included themselves and several enemies
that they faced in the past in addition
sometimes the clones will end up
betraying their creator for various
reasons such as when ace turned against
red after fighting with luffy other than
that the user is also affected by the
standard devil fruit weaknesses number
11 yamato yamato ate the ino inonomi
model okushino makami a mythical zoan
type devil fruit that allows her to
transform into a divine wolf as well as
a human divine wolf the transformation
greatly bolsters her physical abilities
and as a carnivorous zoen presumably
bestows heightened predatory instincts
on top of equipping her with canine
fangs and claws well suited for combat
more specifically the wolf beauty form
seems to come with a dramatic increase
in physical strength in yamato's case
enough to let her clash near evenly with
her father kaido an emperor of the sea
while the latter has assumed his
extremely powerful human dragon form
moreover as with other fruits of the
mythical zoen variety this one blesses
the user with at least one special
ability in particular the user is unable
to produce cold and nice which they can
expel as blasts from their mouth or
otherwise appear from their body and can
even use such ability without
transforming in hybrid form yamato
prefers to still wield her cannibal to
keru as she does in her human form
enhancing her melee combat prowess for
defense yamato may collate her body in a
layer of ice to absorb damage like armor
or erect protective walls of ice